I love the energy in the serve guys yes
you had the gym - so talk to me Naomi
Harris in this Arroyo Tyrese just you
said she was part of the reason you
signed up for this she's still
commanding in this and like she says
it's not often that a female gets to
lead a cop drama soon as happen yes
happened Graham never it was incredible
to have Tyrese and Naomi I mean give
Oscar level performances hands down
anytime you could get someone like Naomi
that can actually command the screen and
give you every bit of what you need in a
film being vulnerable being scared being
tough being witty
those are hard levels to hit into action
film yeah you know at the center of the
movie is it is a intense fun training
day Sicario style movie right crazy
what's going on and throwing popcorn in
your mouth but then when you have those
nuances those those very small moments
in the film that actually register about
what's going on in the culture to that
yeah that's when the movie actually
takes another turn and that's when the
performances to me become award-worthy
yeah because it is extremely hard to
have a film like this which is fun and
then on a dime you turn and begin to
tell people about being the change and
both characters actually change things
around them and it's beautiful man I'm
excited and I can't wait for everybody
in Canada to see that thing you're so
goodness
yes very so good I know like there's
such attentiveness to your performance I
know you said by starring in these
franchise movies it's tough to get
offered these rules like isn't that
surprising for people to hear that yeah
I mean thank God Anthony Mackie was busy
[Laughter]
God the usual go twos were unavailable
yeah
it's um you know the the box office
movies obviously will feed your family
and take your brand and energy around
the world and have you in France and
Germany where people don't speak a lick
of English and they know who you are and
that's the gift to be able to travel
with your art and you just wrapped fast
night really a couple days ago yeah yeah
you know one thing I will say to all of
the Canadian fans that's going to see
this interview first of all thank you
all for watching the interview this long
and you know folks got a short attention
span I want to invite you guys into an
experience I want to invite you guys
into a vulnerable place you should never
be the type of person to say you know I
feel bad about what they are dealing
with when you're a human being rather
you white black American Canadian we
want people to be a little more in touch
and in tune with the reality of what it
is to be black in America and that's
what this movie does it puts you right
there in the front seat I loved ER but I
don't really know if this movie is fun
this movie is vulnerable yeah it puts
you in that place and it gives you a
real world view of what it's like to be
black in the ghetto in the inner city
where we're on the receiving end of
orchestrated corruption crime drama
dysfunction and this constant friction
between the police and poverty and
ghettos and inner city and the way Dion
went about directing this movie which is
just brilliant
you got awards coming too and it makes
you feel like you're a fly on the wall
yeah it really makes you feel like damn
I'm not from there I may be white I may
be Asian I may be whatever but damn I'm
able to really get a sense of the real
vulnerabilities of what it's like to be
black in America and that's what we want
and that's what I into while doing this
role I did it for Eric garner I did it
for Tupac biggie I did it for Nipsey
Hussle I did it for Tamir rice Trayvon
Martin I did it for the young lady we
just lost in Dallas who just got killed
in her living room while playing a video
game this real you know this ain't play
play they saying hee hee ha ha this is
about as real as it gets and this is my
personal win by for y'all to go watch
this movie yeah I don't know we're done
I'll just say as a Canadian this was a
really powerful movie to watch and we
are aware what's happening down here and
yeah for people like you to do stories
like this think it's really important to
shine a light on it and yeah as a kids
we are very aware what's happening there
right you guys are lending your voice to
this so